wir bauen heute in paletten hochbeet das
könnt ihr sowohl auf dem balkon
aufstellen als auch draußen im garten
für die seitenwände verwenden wir
einfach die paletten so dass man die im
grunde nur zusammen schrauben muss und
schon steht das ganze das ist super
günstig und das ganze geht ist in
weniger als einer stunde aufgebaut wir
haben um an die paletten zu kommen bei
verschiedenen firmen in unserer stadt
angerufen und dann haben wir ja viel
stück geschenkt bekommen ich blende hier
mal die anderen materialien ein die man
braucht hochbeete können ja super teuer
sein aber wenn man günstig an paletten
kommt und vielleicht noch die eine
schraube oder die andere planer aus dem
keller hervor kam dann kann man sich so
ein hochbeet für fast null euro bauen
wir bauen das hochbeet jetzt auf dem
balkon aber wie gesagt es geht genauso
gut im garten auf die unterschiede gehe
ich dann gleich noch ein die langen
seiten des beetes bestehen einfach aus
ganz normalen paletten wo man jetzt auch
nichts abschneiden muss oder so und für
die kurzen seiten haben wir jeweils eine
palette so eingekürzt dass das beet eine
für uns und unseren balkon ruth positive
hat also da könnt ihr das bild einfach
so breit machen wie ihr und das gerne
habt als wir die paletten für die kurzen
seiten zugesagt haben haben wir das an
der außenseite überstehende brett bis
zum nächsten klotz in der palette also
da sind ja immer diese plätze haben wir
ein gekürzt weil das sonst so seltsam ab
stehen würde ich hoffe ihr versteht was
ich meine jetzt kannst du die paletten
einfach miteinander verschrauben und
wenn das ganze ein bisschen wacklig ist
dann ist es ganz praktisch wenn man an
der innenseite des beetes winkel
verwendet unser hochbeet soll auf dem
balkon stehen deswegen brauchen wir
einen boden und wollen das beet auch
wasserdicht mit teichfolie auskleiden
hier schneidet gerade die teichfolie so
zu dass sie ein gutes stück größer ist
als das usb brett dass wir als boden
verwenden damit wir die teichfolie
gleich an den seiten hochziehen können
um das beet unten abzudichten nicht wir
haben beim aufbauen darauf geachtet dass
die unterseite des beetes nach oben
schaut das ist einfach in unserem fall
die hässliche hätte gewesen ansonsten
gibt es da nicht viel zu beachten das
ist ja oben und unten normalerweise
gleich aber so können wir jetzt einfach
den boden oben an schrauben und das bild
dann einfach umdrehen
wir haben das hoch bei der jetzt auf dem
balkon aufgebaut aber man kann jetzt
genauso gut im gemüsegarten aufbauen für
uns war es hier wichtig dass das
überschüssige wasser nicht einfach unten
raus läuft und jeder eine pfütze auf dem
balkon bildet deswegen haben wir die usb
platte und verschraubt und das alles
dicht gemacht aber einem normalen
gemüsegarten ist es ja gar nicht schlimm
wenn das was da unten raus laufen kann
das ist sogar besser für die pflanzen
wenn man dann nicht gefallen ist dass
sich das staunässe bildet aber im garten
jetzt ein anderes problem das sind die
filme also die haben wir hier auf dem
balkon nicht aber draußen eben schon und
deswegen würde ich wenn ihr das bild im
garten aufbaut statt der usb platte
unten den kaninchendraht dran tackern
könnt ihr auch die teichfolie weglassen
so dass ihr die mäuse aussperrt und das
wasser immer noch ablaufen kann hier
kleide ich gerade den unteren teil des
beetes somit folie aus dass dann am ende
keine schlange so schaffen balkon laufen
kann aber man kann da auch andere sachen
für verwenden also ich hatte diese
teichfolie einfach noch im keller liegen
vielleicht habt ihr noch irgendeine
andere plane irgendwann liegen die ihr
verwenden könnt ich finde es viel
schöner wenn man einfach das beste aus
dem macht was man hat dann ist es auch
viel günstiger und man muss nicht lauter
neue sachen kaufen die seiten haben wir
statt mit teichfolie mit noppenfolie
ausgekleidet in dem fall würde ich
wirklich eine stabile abdichtungen wie
zb die noch in folie verwenden weil das
beta an manchen stellen lücken hat eben
immer zwischen den brettern der paletten
und sich die erde sonst durch drücken
könnte wenn man eine folie verwendet die
vielleicht schneller reis ich habe beide
folien mit einem schlag tucker fixiert
und dann haben wir oben auf der
bettkante sozusagen noch bretter
montiert einfach alles ein bisschen
schöner aussieht weil man dann auch
leichter was ablegen kann und weil das
holz nicht so aus wie das holz der
paletten das ist übrigens an credit
kennt er vielleicht schon aus einem der
anderen videos das hochbeet ist jetzt
ganz schön wuchtig da müsst ihr auf
jeden fall mit der statik von ihrem
balkon aufpassen erst mal schauen ob ihr
da so ein schweres teil überhaupt
aufbauen können aber man kann das ganze
natürlich auch halb so hoch machen indem
man es einfach hier absenkt oder auch
einfach hier absetzt so dass man das in
der höhe variiert kann man immer noch
ganz viele tolle gemüse anpflanzen aber
es ist dann eben nicht mehr ganz so
massig und schwer nächste woche zeigen
wir euch dann wie man das hochbeet
richtig befüllt deswegen gerne den kanal
abonnieren wenn ihr es noch nicht
gemacht habt und sobald das video
erschienen ist verlinkt ich euch das da
drüben und dann geht raus und macht die
welt ein bisschen grün aber teure
hochbeete und wir sehen uns am samstag
wieder um 10 ein neues video teams